In the previous video,
we observed two oddities.
When we first created
our service worker,
it took two refreshes to see the result.
And secondly,
when we changed the service worker,
we didn't seem to pick up that change.
The life cycle of service worker
is one of the most complex parts.
Once you get your head around this bit,
the rest is easy.
So we had our page open all ready,
then we added code to
register a service worker.
Then we hit refresh.
Hitting refresh spawned a new Window
client, then the request went off to
the network, we got a response back,
and the old Window client went away.
It might not seem like there's
an overlap between the old page and
the new page when you hit refresh,
but there is.
For example, if the response came back
indicating that the browser should
save the resource to disk
Vajra download dialog,
then the old window would
have stayed around.
But in this case, the response was
a page, so we got rid of the old one.
>From our page requests went out for
our CSS images, but
also a shiny new JavaScript,
which registered the service worker.
We didn't see request log from this page
because the Service Worker only takes
control of pages when they're loaded,
and
this page was loaded before
the service worker existed.
That means any additional requests
this page makes will bypass
the Service Worker.
But then we refresh the page
creating a new window client and
because our Service Worker was up and
running, it took control of it.
Therefore, the request went to
the Service Worker as did all
of the subresources.
So that explains why it took two
refreshes to see logged requests.
But what about when we change
the thing we were logging yet
still saw requests being logged
,which was our old code.
If a page loads Vajra Service Worker,
it will check for
an update to the service
worker in the background.
And if it finds it has changed as in
the resources and byte identical,
it becomes the next version.
But it doesn't take control, it waits.
It won't take over until all pages
using the current version are gone.
This ensures there’s only one version
of your site running a given time like
native apps.
Unfortunately, a refresh doesn't
let the new version take over.
This is due to the overlap between
Window clients we saw earlier.
There isn't actually a moment when
the current active service worker
isn't in use.
For that to happen,
this page needs to close or
navigate to a page that isn't
controlled by the Service Worker.
When it does that,
the new service worker takes over and
future page loads will
go through the new one.
Let's put this knowledge to practice.
So as before if I refresh the page, I'm
still getting these old console logs.
But if I navigate away then click back,
the logs so difference.
The new service workers running.
This update process may sound
complicated at first but
it's actually the same update
process browsers such as Chrome use.
Chrome will download
the update in the background,
but it won't take over until
the browser closes and opens again.
It notifies the user that there's
an update ready by changing the color of
this icon.
Later in the course we'll also
notify users of updates to Witter.
When the browser refetches a service
worker looking for updates,
it will go through the browser cache
as pretty much all requests do.
Because of this I strongly recommend
keeping a cache time on your service
workers short.
In fact, I go for cache time of zero
on all my service worker projects.
And that's what Witter uses as well.
As a safety precaution, if you set your
service worker script to cache for
more than a day, the browser will ignore
that and just set the cache to 24 hours.
That doesn't mean your service worker
will stop working after 24 hours.
It just means that update
checks will bypass
the browser cache if the service
worker it has is over a day old.
Okay that's the life cycle
theory out of the way.
In the next chapter,
we're going to look at some deft tools
that show you what state
the Service Worker is in.